you're not just amelia thermopolis you
are
amelia mignonette thermopolis renaldi
princess of genovia
i'm a completely klutzy person so before
i met her i'm like oh god please don't
let me trip over anything
and i i met her and i held up my hand
like this andrews it's so nice to meet
you
and she pulled me into the warmest hug
and gave me a kiss on the cheek and said
we're gonna have a great time and we did
in 2001 the world was introduced to
jenovia's newest
heir to the throne in the princess
diaries
me a princess
shut up annie hathaway is
just she's going to be a huge star the
film about unpopular san francisco girl
turned real-life
princess mia thermopolis continues to be
a disney classic
oh cool he didn't realize it was frozen
what should we do well we should take
that much too
let's do the same thing oh thing i loved
about playing mia was because she was a
15 year old and she was just in
the middle of making the transition from
adolescent to adult to realizing that
life isn't about you it's about you in
the context of the world and what you
can do for other
people the meg cabot book turned movie
was anne hathaway's first film role
i was so happy because i really wanted
this role and it's such a brilliant role
and it's working with such good people
and
it was really a dream come true and
little known fact the princess diaries
was not the original title
back then it was called the princess of
tribeca i said can i audition for that
while i'm out here and they said well
they're worried that you're a little old
i'm like please just get me an audition
and i swear i won't let you down
with anne's introduction to disney we
also had julie andrews big return to the
studio
the last film that i made for walt
disney was mary poppins
we actually filmed on exactly the same
sound stage where we'd filmed mary
poppins
and i think they have a little plaque
outside the door announcing that fact
um it was brought back a lot of memories
and it turns out playing queen clarisse
rinaldi was a role she could not refuse
i would like to bestow upon you the
honor of the um
genovian order of the uh
genovian order of the rose
to have a role handed to one like this
wonderful lady and to wear all those
gorgeous costumes of
armani and valentino and wear those
marvelous tiaras i had an absolutely
wonderful time
another celeb who could not refuse a
role in this film was
mandy moore who played mia's school
rival lana
thomas
mamma mia look who's trying to fit in
now
it was good like stress reliever to come
to set and be able to be mean to
everybody i don't know
to play like a challenge to be somebody
so different from yourself was fun too
the princess diaries was mandy's first
film role as well as
sandra os who had a small but
unforgettable part
playing vice principal gupta the queen
is coming
for late director gary marshall the
princess diaries was also
a family affair his granddaughters lily
and charlotte played the two girls who
asked mia for her autograph
and his daughter kathleen was cast as
queen clarice's assistant charlotte
well i get nervous sometimes because
there's a lot of pressure in
doing a movie so i like to surround
myself with people
who love me somehow despite myself so i
work with a lot of relatives
working behind the scenes with gary was
whitney houston who was a
producer for the film she came down on
the set a couple of times and
said hello and she kept her eye on
things and
gary had a birthday one day and she came
down especially for him
and she's a lovely lady the princess
diaries got the
foot popped seal of approval of fans
around the world
but most importantly it was the
beginning of a beautiful career for anne
and created another iconic disney role
for julie
you had it already how did you know i'd
even be here because i recognize the
same
spirit in you as someone else i know
who me
it just works because the whole point of
the movie is that mia comes full circle
and realizes so much about herself as a
person and it's reflected in the way she
looks and so by the end
when she you know has made the final
transition
mia was so inspirational for me and i
learned so much from her and i hope
other people learn from her too because
she's really a great character
[Music]